this is dave klein reading for jessica
howard for its next adventure bethesda
is taking its popular elder scrolls and
fallout formula into space announced
back in 2018 starfield is bethesda's
first new ip in 25 years and as such
there is a lot of hype surrounding the
upcoming project and perhaps just as
many questions in an attempt to answer
at least a few of them and help you keep
up to date with what's going on with
starfield we've compiled everything we
know about the game so far
starfield is confirmed to release on
xbox series x slash s and pc game
director todd howard said being able to
focus exclusively on xbox and pc is in
the best interest of starfield however
he definitely hears and feels for
playstation owners who won't be able to
play it you don't ever want to leave
people out right he said but at the end
of the day your ability to focus and say
this is the game i want to make these
are the platforms i want to make it on
and being able to really lean in on
those is going to make for a better
product some portion of the bethesda
fanbase continues to believe that
starfield could release on playstation
but that seems extremely unlikely given
that microsoft now owns bethesda
while starfield was originally scheduled
to release on november 11 2022 the same
day that elder scrolls 5 skyrim did back
in 2011 the game has since been delayed
it's now scheduled to come out sometime
during the first half of 2023
back at e3 2018 bethesda teased
starfield for the first time with a very
brief trailer that gives only the barest
sense of what it might be like the
trailer shows the sun flaring over a
planet before also revealing a space
station with a very current technology
look a second later a ripon space
appears that seems to suck everything in
it has the look of a bright star trek
like warp field but it could be anything
a singularity a wormhole a space anomaly
or a cool special effect and your
trailer on at this point who knows after
a long wait bethesda finally unveiled a
new trailer for starfield at e3 2021
it's yet another short glimpse but it
further nails down the look and feel the
game will have the trailer follows an
astronaut preparing to lift off from an
alien planet all the while a monologue
plays discussing the endless frontier of
space during june 2022's xbox bethesda
games showcase bethesda gave fans the
closer look at starfield they've been
waiting for with a significant chunk of
gameplay and more details regarding the
game's size skill tree and space
exploration don't feel like giving it a
watch don't sweat it we'll go into
everything shown shortly
in november 2021 bethesda kicked off a
new video series for starfield called
into the star field in this series game
developers including todd howard
discussed the ambitious rpg and reveal
new details about what fans can expect
in the debut episode the endless pursuit
howard art director matt carafano and
studio director angela browder talked
about how the studio's ambition and
passion have shaped the team and what
they are hoping to achieve with
starfield karfano said starfield is more
grounded and realistic than skyrim
though at its heart the two projects
share an ambition to give players the
freedom to explore got a more realistic
science-based backing to it whereas
skyrim is sort of a you know an epic
fantasy this is a more grounded
game and a grounded setting about
exploration so i think that gives us a
different take on how we make everything
howard said the mechanics of starfield
compared to skyrim are entirely
different though there are some
similarities one of those is how
starfield is presented with a first
person camera with the third person
option which he believes helps makes
things seem more believable being able
to
watch the sunset
and nighttime come and just sit there
and watch the world go by
seems like it's not
gameplay
but it is
vital to how you feel
through the rest of it according to
browder there has to be an emotional
trigger that occurs i think as time has
gone on we're able to paint an even
better picture that triggers that
emotional thing
also in the video howard teased that
starfield has not won but two step out
moments referencing the points in past
bethesda games where you leave the
starter area and step out into the open
world what those are he wouldn't say and
seem to want to leave it as a surprise
bethesda is known for its expansive open
world rpgs like the elder scrolls series
and the fallout series however both
series massive worlds pale in comparison
to the universe we'll be exploring in
starfield during june 2022's xbox
bethesda game showcase howard confirmed
players will be able to visit over 1 000
planets throughout the game while a
handful of these locations are
full-fledged cities like the hub city of
new atlantis many will be procedurally
generated and ripe for exploration
others such as the desert moon of crete
lie somewhere in the middle with
outposts occupied by treacherous space
bandits
according to howard starfield is also
more of a hardcore rpg than bethesda's
previous work something made very clear
in our first look at starfield's
character creator while the physical
aspect of the game's character creation
is pretty par for the course the wide
variety of backgrounds and traits
players are able to choose from is
impressive based on your choices your
character will have their own unique set
of talents and flaws that can make your
intergalactic adventure truly your own
however this is not where starfill's
emphasis on customization ends the game
will also allow players to customize the
look and performance of their guns and
spacecrafts as well as construct their
own outposts the mechanics for building
these outposts seem significantly more
complex than those in fallout 4 allowing
for even more personalization and
creativity in designing your base beyond
base building and the usual exploration
and con that we've come to expect from
bethesda games players will also be able
to freely fly their own spacecraft and
engage in galactic dogfights recent
gameplay also showed off a lock-picking
mechanic and a persuasion mechanic
inspired by oblivion
while we might not know just what
starfield's main campaign entails thanks
to the recent xbox bethesda games
showcase we do have a lot more
information regarding its setting based
on starfield's first gameplay trailer
the game will be set in the year 2330
long after man conquered the stars in
fact humans are so well adapted to space
travel they've managed to settle a
whopping 50 light-year radius around
their own solar system this area is
referred to as the settled systems while
you'll also be able to explore seemingly
every nook and cranny of these systems
the main hub of starfield is new
atlantis capital city of the united
colonies and home to constellation the
last group of space explorers starfield
begins with your character the space
fairer receiving an invitation to join
this organization however the united
colonies aren't the only space-faring
society there's also the free start
collective who call aquila city their
home while these two factions are no
longer at war with one another the end
of their conflict is still fresh and
their peace is an uneasy one in addition
to the united colonies and free star
collective there are also a few other
notable groups bethesda has mentioned
ryujin industries the crimson fleet and
house of baroon as you might be able to
infer based on their names ryujean
industries is a mega corporation the
crimson fleet is a band of space pirates
and house varun is well a religious cult
to put it bluntly based on the game's
intense focus on role-playing it seems
safe to say you'll be able to join up
and or get in all sorts of trouble with
these folks during 2021's tokyo game
show howard revealed that starfield has
over 150 000 lines of dialogue more than
any bethesda game before it while your
character will not have voice acting it
seems like just about everyone else will
making for a very immersive experience
we should also mention companion
characters make a return in starfield
with vasco the utility robot confirmed
as one of them last but certainly not
least howard also announced the main
campaign should take around 30 to 40
hours to complete to put that into
perspective fallout 4's main campaign
takes around 30 to beat while skyrim
takes about 25.
in september 2020 bethesda released a
statement about how much the acquisition
by microsoft and the release of its new
xbox series x and s were impacting the
work the studio is doing on its games
howard says with each new console cycle
we evolved together from bringing mods
to consoles with fallout 4 to the latest
technologies fueling xbox series x slash
s these new systems are optimized for
the vast worlds we love to create with
generational leaps not just in graphics
but cpu and data streaming as well it's
led to our largest engine overhaul since
oblivion with all new technologies
powering our first new ip in 25 years
starfield as well as the elder scrolls
6. for years now bethesda has powered
its games with its creation engine so
this makes it pretty clear that
starfield also uses the creation engine
albeit an overhauled version that takes
into account a whole lot of new
technology and hardware capabilities
this is a bit of an obvious one but it
bears repeating with microsoft's
acquisition of bethesda the publisher
announced that new bethesda games would
appear on xbox game pass at release and
that includes starfield so you'll have
instant access to it on pc and xbox
series x slash s that said starfield
isn't currently available for pre-order
that wraps up everything you need to
know about starfield so far stay tuned
to gamespot for more on starfield and
everything bethesda and i'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]